[موسيقى]
لولا ان الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون
قال للجزيره ان العلاقات بين الجزائر
والمغرب قد وصلت الى نقطه الله عوده لكان
بامكاننا القول ان شهر رمضان المبارك
سيكون كريما ايضا بمزيد من سياسه حوار
الجوار وفتح النوافذ بين المتخاصمين في
المنطقه مقدمه لتشريع ابواب الدبلوماسيه
والاقتصاد
قال رسول الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
الا اخبركم بافضل من درجه الصلاه والصيام
والصدقه قالوا بلى قال اصلاح ذات البيت
الى العناوين
بوتين مطلوب للتوقيف دوليا بتهم جرائم حرب
الاسد في ابوظبي مكرما بطلاقات مدفعيه
تبون العلاقات الجزائريه المغربيه وصلت
الى الحائط المسدود
نقطه
الخارجيه المصريه تحذف مرسي من قائمه
الرؤساء
سعيد ليس مخلص تونس فقط بل بطل استقلالها
ايضا
شوارع باريس من مدينه العطور الى حاويه
نفايات
لاعب ناشئين مانشستر يونايتد الانجليزي
مرتل للقران
[موسيقى]
مرحبا ورمضان مبارك على الصائمين وعلى كل
الناس
للسنه السادسه على التوالي تتربع فنلندا
في تصنيف اممي على عرش البلدان السعيده في
العالم فيما تحل افغانستان في المركز
الاخير عالميا يسبقها لبنان بمقعد واحد
لكن في نفس الوقت تحتل فنلندا السعيده
دائما مركزا متقدما ايضا في قائمه البلدان
المرتفعه بمعدلات الانتحار بينما
افغانستان ولبنان ليس ضمن اول مئه بلد في
انتحار مواطني هلا فينا نقول انه في عنا
مين بيقتلك ما بتضطر تقتل حالك ونستطيع ان
نتحدث بجديه ونقول ان الفرد في مجتمعاتنا
المحكومه بقسوه وافقار يشعر بحب اكبر مما
يشعره الفنلندي وغيره على صعيد العائله
والمحيط الاجتماعي ولا احد يستعيد مثلا
بصحن الحساء الشوربه الذي يقدمه لجاره على
افطارات رمضان انه يترك اثرا من نور يتعدى
الامعاء ليلامس قلوب الناس هي عاده
توارثناها منذ اكثر من
1400 عام والحفاظ عليها قيمه كبيره ولو
بشق تمره للعام السادس على التوالي تتصدر
فنلندا قائمه مؤشر السعاده العالمي في كل
مره تتصدر فنلندا لائحه الشرف في نادي
السعاده يشكك عدد من الفنلنديين في منهجيه
تقرير السعاده العالمي ونتائجه في المجتمع
الفنلندي يعاني مشكلات عديده وترتفع فيه
نسب الاكتئاب والقلق وحالات الانتحار
مفارقه اخرى في هذا العالم الذي يتحدث
كثيرا عن حقوق الاطفال في دول العالم
الثالث
مشاهد صادمه لتلامذه يتسابقون في قاعه
مدرسه في شبه جزيره القرم ضمن دوله
تدريبيه للاطفال على فك وتركيب الاسلحه
الناريه وقد اكد دون خجل رئيس اداره القرن
التابعه لروسيا ان اطفال الروضات شاركوا
ايضا في تدريبات مماثله طفله اخرى في مكان
اخر من هذا العالم لا تتدرب على
الكلاشنكوف بل على اطلاق القنابل النوويه
هي جو اي كيم جو اي ابنه الزعيم الكوري
الشمالي كيم جونغ اون الذي بات يصطحب
طفلته الى التجارب الصاروخيه النوويه
ويدعو جيشه الى ابقاء الاصبع على زناد
السلاح النووي
زعيم كوريا الشماليه يدعو بلاده الى
الاستعداد هجمات نوويه في اي وقت لردع ما
يقول انها حرب محتمله
في صور نشرها تلفزيون الحكومي شوهد كيم
وهو يحضر اختبار اطلاق صاروخ مع ابنته
الصغيره اما ام المفارقات هذا الاسبوع فهي
مذكره توقيف صدرت عن المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه بحق الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
بدعوى مسؤوليته عن جرائم حرب ارتكبت في
اوكرانيا المحاديه لدولته والتي تقول
موسكو ان سياساتها تشكل خطرا على روسيا
وليس في سوريا هذه الجرائم سوريا مليونيه
الضحايا التي عبر الجيش الروسي المحيط
للوصول اليها والقصف والقتال فيها
اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه اليوم
مذكرتي توقيف فيما يتعلق بالوضع في
اوكرانيا ضد الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
وماريا بوفابيلوفا المفوض الرئاسي لحقوق
الطفل في روسيا بتهمه جرائم الحرب
المزعومه حول ابعاد الاطفال من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه المحت الى الاتحاد الروسي
الرئيس بوتين الذي اعتاد على تلقي
المجاملات من قاده دول العالم الثالث حان
الوقت لاي يلعب بنفسه دور المجامل لقد قال
لرئيس الصين
الذي قام بزياره بارزه لبوسكو كسرت عزله
بوتين الدوليه قال له ان روسيا تغار من
تقدم الصين
[موسيقى]
الاسد يدعو الى استمرار الوجود العسكري
الروسي في سوريا الان والى الابد يشير
الاسد صراحه بان الوجود العسكري الروسي في
سوريا يجب ان لا يكون مؤقتا
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات لم تطلق له خلالها المدافع الا
ارض ارض وجو ارض وداخل المدن والقرى
السوريه اطلقت للرئيس السوري بشار الاسد
احدا وعشرين طلقه مدفعيه ترحيبيه به في
ابوظبي التي استقبلته بوافر من التكريم
ورفقت طائره الرئيس السوري لدى دخولها
اجواء دوله الامارات طائرات حربيه ترحيبا
بزياره فخامته ورافق صاحب السمو الشيخ
محمد بن زايد ال نهيان الرئيس الضيف الى
منصه الشرف وعزف السلام الوطني لسوريا
فيما اطلقت المدفعيه 21 طلقه بين المرحبين
بعوده دمشق الى الجامعه العربيه توجه يعلل
نفسه بضروره اعاده سوريا الى الحضن العربي
المكسور
عن اي حضن نتكلم وقد اصبحت الكلمه العليا
في بلاد العرب تتجمع حروفها من امريكا
وشوي من روسيا وشوي من فرنسا
وحديثا الصين
وبالدرجه الثانيه من اسرائيل وايران
وتركيا وحقيقه الامر الحضن العربي غير
موجود يعني حتى لو عادت سوريا الى جامعه
الدول العربيه ماذا سيقدم او يؤخر بلد
مقسم مناطق نفود بلد فيه سيطره روسيه
واستحواذ ايراني بلد في تدخل تركي بلد حتى
في وجود عسكري امريكي وفيه تاثير اسرائيلي
ووجود اسرائيل استكمالا لمصالحه الرياض مع
الاقطاب في المنطقه من انقره وصولا الى
طهران ورشه ترميم العلاقات بين السعوديه
وايران قائمه على اعلى المستويات وكما
استشرفنا في الحلقه الماضيه فان الرياض
وطهران بل معظم اهل السنه والشيعه بمن
فيهم الايرانيون راوا هذا العام هلالا
واحدا وبدا رمضان عند الاغلبيه يوم الخميس
نحو مزيد من التقارب تمضي العلاقات بين
طهران والرياض يرحب الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم بالدعوه التي تلقاها من العاهل
السعودي لزياره المملكه ويؤكد وزير خارجيه
جمهوريه الاسلاميه حسين امير عبد اللهيان
ان تعزيز العلاقات مع السعوديه سيكون
لصالح البلدين وامن المنطقه واستقرارها
الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون اذ
يعتبروا في حديث الى قناه الجزيره نشرت
قناه الجزائر الدوليه مقاطع منه ان
الجزائر لم تكن يوما البادئه في الجفاء مع
المغرب يؤكد ان العلاقات بين البلدين
الجارين الشقيقين قد وصلت الى نقطه لا
عوده
فهل ثمه من يتحرك على المستوى العربي لراس
الصدع وللاصلاح بينهما هل يعقل ان
المصالحه مع اسرائيل وفرنسا ممكنه وليست
ممكنه مع الاخ والشقيق والسؤال موجه
للجميع دون انتقاء ودون استثناء
عليه
الحدود مغلوقه منذ 43 سنه في اكثر من
[موسيقى]
تقريب نقطه لا رجوع واحنا الموقف تاعنا
رانا في رده فعل لن نكون يوما ما البادئين
[موسيقى]
اكد الوزيران على ضروره بذل الجهد من كلا
الدولتين للوصول الى استعاده مسار
العلاقات صوره على هامش هذا اللقاء ضغط
على اللقاء بحد ذاته رغم اهميته
حول الموقف من الرئيس المصري الراحل محمد
مرسي حاله مزدوجه متناقضه بين من يشكل
عندهم مرسي قيمه وجدانيه واخرين يعتبرونه
عدوا لهم اما المحايدون وهم اغلبيه حول
العالم فلديهم تساؤلات تتعلق بمساره الى
مصيره من القصر الى القبر لكن هذا العالم
المحايد نسي مرسي فابى موظف او مسؤول ما
في الخارجيه المصريه ان يستمر هذا التغافل
والنسيان لمرسي
فعلقت على لوحه رؤساء مصر داخل الوزاره
صور رؤساء الجمهوريه المتعاقبين باستثناء
صوره الرئيس المنتخب محمد مرسي وهكذا اعيد
من جديد ذكر مرسي حول العالم دون غيره من
الصور وذلك بعد التقاط الكاميرات اللوحه
اثناء جوله داخل الوزاره للوزير سامح شكري
وضيفه التركي مولود جاويش اوغلو انما
توقفت الميديا العربيه والعالميه عند فكره
انه كان في ست صور لست رؤساء مصريين ما
فيهمش محمد مرسي في تونس انصاره الرئيس
قيس سعيد لم يلغوا رئيسا واحدا من الاطار
بل الغوا جميع رؤساء تونس السابقين في عيد
الاستقلال ورفعوا صور سعيد دون غيره في
مسيره للمناسبه اقيمت في شارع الحبيب
بورقيبه الذي لم ترفع صورته كما هي العاده
مع انه يوصف بقائد استقلال تونس
فالاستقلال الحقيقي برايهم هو ما جاء به
قيس سعيد
الاستقلال الحقيقي هو ما جاء به سيد قيس
سعيد رئيس الجمهوريه التونسي يوم 25 جويله
هو المسار الحقيقي البرلمان الاوروبي قلق
من التحول الاستبدادي في تونس ويطالب
باطلاق سراح جميع معتقل التعسف هذا الموقف
تبنته اغلبيه داخل البرلمان البرنامج
الاوروبي اعرب عن قلقه العميق من التحول
الاستبداد لرئيس السعيد اطلاق سراح جميع
المعتقلين تعسفيا من صحفيين
طبعا اصدقاء قيس سعيد في اليمين المتطرف
الفرنسي دفعوا عنه داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي
وضمن مسار بات معروفا في اوروبا لدرجه ان
الاعلام الفرنسيه الرسميه يتساءل هل تبنى
قيس سعيد نظريات اليمين المتطرف الفرنسي
كما صار سعيد مرجعا يستدل باقواله عند
لهلوبه التطرف الفرنسي ايريك زمور الذي
يريد طرد المسلمين من اوروبا ومنع الاذان
ومنع اسم محمد وهو يصف الاسلام بانه ابشع
من النازيه كذلك تدعم سعيد زعيمه اليمين
المتطرف مارين لوبان التي لا تفوت فرصه
لمهاجمه المسلمين
والاتهامهم بالارهاب كما تصف دين الاسلام
الحنيف بالسرطان الذي يجب استئصاله هؤلاء
الاشرار يحبون عيد اليوم اليمين الفرنسي
تحفظ على هذا القرار
وتقريبا كانت له مداخلات اثناء الجلسه
مناصره لقيس سعيد قبل نحو ثمانيه اشهر
اعلنت محكمه امريكيه الامريكيه من اصل
الليبي خليفه حفتر مجرم حرب ارتكب جرائم
قتل وتعذيب في ليبيا بحسب القرار كما صدر
قرار قضائي امريكي يامر حفتر بدفع تعويضات
لعائلات الضحايا مساعده وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه حضرت الى مقر الجنرال حفتر على
راس وفد حكومي ليس لتبلغه بسحب الجنسيه
الامريكيه منه ولا لتناقش معه استحقاقات
القرارات القضائيه التي تدينه
بل للبحث معه في تسهيل اجراء الانتخابات
الليبيه في ليبيا اجرت مساعده وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه لشؤون الشرق الادنى
بربراليف اجرت محادثات مع خليفه حفتر قائد
الجيش الوطني الليبي وافاد مراسل الحره ان
لقاء خصص لمناقشه التطورات السياسيه في
ليبيا لتمهيد اجراء الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه قبل نهايه العام الجاري يقول
المثل العربي الناس على دين ملوكهم في
ليبيا تشكلون حكومتين للبلاد وقيادتين
للعباد نقيم صلاتين للجمعه في نفس المسجد
واللحظه وهذا ما حدث في مسجد بمحله رقيبه
في مدينه اوباري جنوب ليبيا قام المصلون
الى صلاتهم بامام لهم بينما الخطيب على
المنبر وذلك رفضا لقرار دائره الاوقاف
بتكليفه بالامامه
[موسيقى]
تحت عنوان مقتبس من قول ينسب للخليفه عمر
بن الخطاب رضي الله عنه او كلما اشتهيت
اشتريت داروا الافتاء المصريه تدعو
المواطنين الى التقشف والصبر في ضوء
الازمه الحاده التي يعاني منها الاقتصاد
المصري
لابد ان يكون فقير الفقراء يدخلون الجنه
خالد الجندي عنده برنامج تلفزيوني يومي
اظن في هذه المرحله يشتغل على موجه تمهيد
الناس بالاكل والشرب
ولانه محتاج كل يوم الى فكره جديده طلع
معه انه انشاء الاوتوسترادات والكباري اهم
من الغذاء يعني بس تجوعوا اطلعوا اعملوا
كزدوره على الكوبري والاوتوسترات اتعاملت
الكباري واتعملت الطرق واتعملت الشوارع
واتعملت كده وناس لسه دماغها في حله
الشوربه لسه في ناس دماغها في
حته اللحمه طبعا اللحمه مهمه والشرب مهمه
والاكل مهم والعيش مهم انما في حاجات لها
اولويه في بريوركس في اولويه الاولويه دي
غصب عنك لازم تلجا اليه في اليوم التالي
خرج خالد بفكره جديده وهي ان انشاء مصنع
للاسمده اهم من بناء عشرين الف مسجد
وكنيسه هو لم يذكر الكنائس بهيج اضافها
فافتتاح مصنع اسمده ازوتيه اهم بكتير من
بناء الف مسجد
المصنع ده اللي بيوفر لك رغيف العيش وطبق
المكرونه شيخ خالد بس حضرتك اكلت عيش
ومعكرونه وكافيار من المسجد مش هيك
[موسيقى]
هكذا اصبح حال مدينه الاضواء التي تحولت
الى مدينه للقمامه ومعالمها الاثريه من
برج ايفل الى قوس النصر بدا اكثر ما
يميزها هو التجمع اطنان من القمامه حولها
وذلك بعد اضراب عمال النظافه مئات الالاف
في معظم المدن الفرنسيه خرجوا الى الشوارع
بسبب رفع سن التقاعد 62 سنه الى 64 سنه
هكذا تحولت شوارع مدينه العطور باريس الى
حاويات مكشوفه للنفايات بسبب سياسات
باكرون الذي يعيش ازمات في فرنسا وفي كل
مكان بالعالم
البطه العرجاء لقب جديد تطلقه الصحافه
الغربيه على الماكرون رئيسه الوزراء
الفرنسيه احتلت عناوين الصفحه الاولى
لنيويورك تايمز وحسب هذه اليوميه فان
ماكرون في وضعيه لا يحسد عليها نفس الملاح
الصحافه البريطانيه صحيفه ديل التلغراف
وصفات الرئيس الفرنسي بالبطه العرجاء
وبانه لم يعد بامكانه الحكم وحسب جريده
الايطاليه فان الرئيس الفرنسي تحدى
البرلمان والشعب معا فيما اعتبرت صحيفه
المانيه ان طريقه حكم ماكرون فشلت فشلا
ذريعا في سابقه تاريخيه تحصل مع رئيس
امريكيا سابق جرى التلويح قضائيا في
واشنطن للرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بالتوقيف المحتمل بسبب دفعه مبلغا ماليا
لممثله اباحيه قبيل انتخابات 2016
نصف ثرواتنا تهدر على الشراشف الحمراء او
الخضراء يعلق معلق من هوليود
الحمله الغربيه على مونديال قطر التاريخي
لم يشفى غليلها بعد صحفي سويدي فاجا نجم
الكره السويدي زلاتان ابراهيموفيتش بسؤال
عن مونديال قطر اراد فيه استدراجه الى
الانتقاد فسرعه زلتا باجابات متلاحقه منح
فيها مونديال قطر علامه عشر على عشره من
كل الجوانب بوابه
[موسيقى]
اورجاني
موطن
[موسيقى]
اخيرا امير ابراهيموفيتش اللاعب
الداجيستاني الناس في نادي مانشستر
يونايتد الانجليزي ابهر متابعيه بتلاوته
ايات كلمات من سوره الفرقان بصوت مميز
وباتقان للغه العربيه لكن للتوضيح وكانه
اخطا في لفظ كلمه عميان في اخر الايه
الكريمه والذين لا يشهدون
الزور العظيم الروك راما والذين اذا ذكروا
بايات ربهم لم يخره عليها
ثم لم يخروا عليها سما واوعيانا
[موسيقى]
ختاما سال طاغيه طاغيه اكثر طغيانا منه كم
تظن اننا سنعيش ونقش طولا وعرضا كما نستهي
ونساء فقال لا ادري لكنني متفائل لان
سيدنا فرعون عاش تسعين سنه رد عليه لكنه
كان بارا بامه يقال بينما المرحومه والدتك
نظمت ديوانا في عقوقك وفي الغضب عليك
فقطعه قائلا لم يثبت تاريخيا ان فرعون كان
مرضيا عند امه ما شاء الله قال الطاغوت
الاصغر وهل اصبحتم جنابكم علم تاريخ ضحكت
طاغوت الكبير وقال بالطبع لا لكن هذا
فرعون يا رجل وليس اي انسان اتريدوا لي ان
اكون جاهلا بسيره قدوتنا الذي لم يذكره
احد بخير قط الى اللقاء واذا
[موسيقى]
وامرني اني احكم هالبلد
[تصفيق]
وانا لا بعرف احكم ولا اكتب سنه
خربت الدنيا خربت البلد وشو همي وشو
بيهمني شو هم شو بيهمني مثل مصرياتي كلها
كلها كل مصرياتي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]